Also, I started doing nicotine that Dr. artist recommended is nicotine not good for some people. I wonder if
It made my cyst grow by cyst in my pay curious grew almost two millimeters. I
Have been more sick than usual lately and my blood work has been better than the last two years
so
Yeah, I just I would be careful when you know, there's a lot of
Videos out there on the internet. I did see Dr. Artis's video that he said he was gonna wear
two milligram nicotine patch the rest of his life because it's gonna be good for him
It's like
So a sick sometimes these people will just make videos in order to get views
Sometimes they just make videos to sell products. I
Think more of it is just to sound just to make get views and to keep up their audience. I don't get this whole
I just don't get this whole
Instagram thing this whole TikTok thing I literally told
Nice to know a couple people I staff the other day that I just feel like I just want to shut down our whole Instagram
It just bothers me so much that there's so much misinformation out there
Now again, I'm not necessarily against doing the nicotine patch if it's helping you, but
Okay, it's just because you if there's a study that shows that it's good for this is that everybody should do that all the time
I mean good assakes. We'd all be on 4,000 different supplements
So just be careful of those. That's why we do the zoom. That's why we do the cheek slom so
That you're not on 4,000 different supplements because you could find an article
Literally, maybe not 4,000 probably you could probably find an article or multiple articles on at least
Thousand different supplements that say that there could be extremely beneficial for cancer or whatever condition you're
You're dealing with are you supposed to take all that stuff?
It's just it's just silly. So just be careful of what you're doing out there
Things can be bad for you too
Besides the fact that how pure is though are those nicotine patches?
How pure are those? What other chemicals are in there?
What are they have to put in the product in order for it to work as a patch? I just don't know, you know
What you're giddy in this stuff. So I
Don't know if that's what caused your sister girl. I can't say that I don't know but